indeed I was at the University of
Washington and indeed at some point I'd
human-computer interaction that
James who caused human interaction to
become visible at University of
Washington I started in a I and my
advisor and I started working on user
interfaces that adapted themselves to
their users and we had a number of great
ideas and eventually we came up with
another one we thought why don't we
involve actual people in our research
and that actually proved quite difficult
because neither of us had much
experience with HCI and we tried to look
for HTC expertise throughout University
of Washington and they were only a
handful of people and they were already
over committed so eventually I found a
mentor at Microsoft Research marriage
I've insky and then James showed up and
actually created a large vibrant HCI
community at University of Washington
and they just gave gave a talk that two
days ago and while when I was starting
at University of Washington there were
maybe a handful of people who knew what
HCI was and when I gave at Uggla the 120
people in and out in the audience so
thank you James I am the human-computer
interaction department at Harvard
University I share this this privilege
with power one of my students a survivor
of Stanford so we do quite a few things
because you know departments have to
have broad interests so we do have broad
interests we work quite a lot on user
interfaces and systems that adapt
themselves to their users this is too
large extent motivated by the
observation that one size fits all a
design practice is inherently
discriminatory by designing by hype
optimizing our designs for particular
populations for particular assumptions
about our populations we systematically
even if in small ways discriminate some
groups of people and these
discriminations adapt so my initial work
was on adapting systems to people with
motor impairments and vision impairments
I was very frustrated with the state of
public discourse on accessibility
because we still strive to make systems
to make access passable but what we
really need to be doing is to make
access equitable
if a person with impairments needs three
times as much time as everybody else to
complete the task on with a user
interface and we need and we spend eight
hours a day in front of our computers
then you know this three-time
amplification of the effort actually
means that that person is professionally
or personally or educationally civil yet
severely disadvantaged I am trying to
identify and to eradicate these
inequalities that arise through
one-size-fits-all design as a as an as a
professor as an educator I became very
much interested in how we teach what it
means to teach what it means to learn
and some of my research went into this
direction some of the original work on
learning and teaching actually looked at
a fairly exotic domains like learning
how to detect landmines and more
recently I brought it back into the
regular classrooms I also worked quite a
lot on human computation so as Michael
mentioned I am very interested in
intelligent systems in systems that in
some way exhibit intelligent behavior
for a long time I worked on machine
intelligence as the source of the kind
of adaptive and intelligent behavior in
my systems but they realize that you
know people are pretty smart too so why
not leverage human intelligence behind
my interactive intelligent systems and a
lot of our recent work in this space
tried to step away from paid
crowdsourcing and toyed what we call
organic crowdsourcing where human
computation happens as a byproduct of
activities that people find inherently
valuable and yet another branch of our
research has to do with developing new
empirical tools for human-computer
interaction research so I remember when
toward the end of my graduate school I
went to a party met Mary chewinsky she
pulled out her iPhone and showed me a
nap and said see this app my daughter
did it and she's got 10,000 users and at
that moment I realized that a motivated
teenager had access to a larger quantity
of data than an average HCI professor
head in a lifetime and I thought that
that wasn't quite right and I thought we
should do something about it that we
should invest a little bit of effort
into expanding our
pirkle toolkit search you know when the
when it was right we could do more than
just run a lab study with N equals 15 so
this breaking out of the lab the
expansion of the empirical toolkit is
what I would like to share with you
today we've worked on a number of
projects in this space we've built a
system that unobtrusively monitors
people's motor behavior as they operate
their computers in the wild and tries to
pull out lab quality data from these
natural interactions we've obviously
worked out but on paid crowdsourcing and
enter valuation of you I innovations
then we moved it took it kind of into
the organic space and we've built lab in
the wild a platform for conducting
empirical behavioral research with with
people in the real world and we've also
started working on ways of reporting
potentially disturbing results back to
participants in a way that is ethical
and not disturbing and specifically by
working with people who are doing
biomonitoring people who are discovering
pollutants in your in your tissue sent
in new environments how do you tell
people what you found in their lives
even if you don't exactly know what that
means because obviously I'm measuring
chemicals who's who's impacts are not
yet known that's the that's the point of
novel biomonitoring research and we're
bringing it back to the human-computer
interaction because some of the things
that we measure in large-scale studies
are things related to people's
perception and cognition and people get
upset when if if I study tells them that
maybe there's something unusual about
how they think of how they perceive the
world and they would like to they on the
one hand they they really want to know
their results on the other hand we also
need to communicate them in such a way
that they understand what these results
actually mean and what are the answer in
teaching the science so I would like to
tell you about just two of the projects
that we did in this space and focusing
particularly on lab in the wild I'll
tell you I'll convince you that the data
that we get in the wild are valid
I'll try to share with you some of the
insights from from that project ways
that we believe the design decisions
that we've made that we believe are
responsible for the high quality of the
data and I'll also like to share with
you to pieces of novel research that
we've done that we could not have done
without lab in the wild so I would like
to share with you some of the research
results that were enabled by this
expanded empirical toolkit but to begin
with I'll tell you a little bit about
measuring people's motor performance in
the wild it's a project I conducted with
a with an undergraduate who is now at
Cornell University and with Caterina
reineke who is a postdoc at Harvard and
his now a professor at University of
Washington Seattle so the motivation is
that we conduct quite a lot of research
that requires some understanding of
people's motor performance we they want
to understand motor performance across
population now we want to understand how
people interact with novel devices or
with Neville software we can perform
these measurements by inviting people in
the lab but often the scale is not quite
right all we would like to see actually
what happens when people are not in the
lab and focusing entirely on this test
but what happens when they're in a real
environment interact with the computer
for extended periods of time get
fatigued get distracted anything else
we've got a lot of ways of reasoning
about motor performance data but all of
these existing analysis tools assume
that we are presented with very clean
data which is actually very different
from what you get if you just observe
people's motor performance in the wild
the data that we know how to analyze our
data that that I product of deliberate
and targeted pointing movements when
when a person is trying to perform an
input activity a user interface activity
as quickly and as accurately as possible
but in the real world they may be
discontinued the task they may be
distracted by a conversation they may be
distracted by TV anything else can be
happening so how can we get the clean
data the data that we know how to
analyze from the sea of you know
of interactions that we observe in the
real world so what we really want to do
that there's you know micro problem that
we want to solve is that given a
movement trajectory we would like to be
able to tell whether that movement was a
deliberate targeted movement or whether
it was something that was affected by
any kind of distraction the cognitive
perceptual or anything else and given my
background I decided to take a
data-driven approach so why don't we get
a whole bunch of representative data and
try to figure out computationally
through machine learning and model that
would be able to distinguish between
targeted delbert movements and
everything else and this proved to be a
somewhat interesting task a typical way
of thinking about building a classifier
a machine learning system that is able
to tell this is deliberate this is not
is to collect an data some of it
representing deliberate targeted
movements and some representing other
movements so movements that that
represents the full range of
distractions that people can be
presented with if we've got something
like that we can we can indeed a train a
classifier and it's quite easy to
imagine how we can get a corpus of of
clean data of positive examples of
deliberate targeted movements all we
have to do is invite people to the lab
and have them participate in a in an
experiment in which they perform as
quickly in the security and possible but
where do we get data that are only
negative examples in movements that are
that are distracted and that are
representative of all of the
distractions that people can experience
in the real world turns out that such
data set will be very hard to obtain
what instead we have is you know
observations from the real world that
are a mix of both delbert targeted
movements when a person wanted to do
something quickly and all sorts of
distracted movements so what we have
over here rather than having positive
and negative examples we have positive
examples and the sea of unlabeled
examples what can we do with this it
turns out that there is a very rare
machine learning
a method for dealing with such
situations and we found it and we
applied it to this task and were able to
build an effective classifier by taking
a lab data and by taking data that we
collected in situ in the wild by
building a Firefox extension it's in
fairly old project there was a browser
called Firefox them um yes the your
basic position in this project has been
there's models that we know work and you
have noisy data I mean in so that's that
in the real world that model seems to
really struggle so how do we make it fit
the model like the obvious other
question would be is our model wrong
yeah like should we be maybe revising
our core like how do you think about and
produce its law limits and it's
corollaries so I'll rephrase it to make
sure that I get it you're you are saying
we've got a whole bunch of way of
analyzing motor performance data that
relies on clean data produced in the lab
perhaps well she does happen people
occasionally you know I've focused
enough on a touch that they are not
distracted by anything else and I think
that there is value to you know
separating effects of different
processes inside our bodies that there
is the the you know neuromotor process
that we want to study via via Fitts law
then there is you know the high level
cognitive processes that cause us to
attempt to screaming children to think
about you know what is the next button
that I want to click right which is
separate from actually wanting to click
it so I think there's value in keeping
this separation and they think rather
than fixing our tools for analyzing the
data I thought it was appropriate to to
find ways to make our data fit our
analytical tools in this case I thought
it was the right choice so you know very
big quick summary of the data is that
given the noisy data that we collect in
the scituate I with a with a classifier
that I just described and the noisy date
felted with our tool were essentially
statistically indistinguishable from
data that we obtained from the same
people through a controlled experiment
in the lab there were some nuances to it
it really helped to to know what targets
people were clicking on and where these
targets were located and how lives they
were when we had that knowledge that the
accuracy of our system improved and also
you know obviously people are different
from one another you know if somebody
has a motor impairment or showing
permanent age-related changes in the
Indian motor performance that they
targeted and deliberate movement will
often look like a distracted movement of
somebody who is younger and table able
bodied so our system also gets better if
it has a chance to collect some amount
of unlabeled data from a person
understand the kind of variance in that
person's data normalize it and and then
perform the classification but it it
works also reasonably well even if we do
not know where the targets are and
people have no prior exposure to that
person yes sir where you have a large
enough dataset it can be even a
completely stochastic data set and you
are searching for particular patterns
that you have identified in the lab you
will find those patterns because your
data set is large and varied enough that
they exist and if you simply filter out
to get you know patterns that you want
to find AG lab you will find lab data in
the real world but it fits you know you
have no idea what proportion of the real
world data that data works i mean you
know that but people sleeping identified
for some sprinkle so is there is there
in this method does the method rely on
the fact that you can't really over you
can't have to learn to data set or you
need a certain amount of representative
fit of the actual data to the mall at
you're searching for so i'm not exactly
sure what the question is but that will
give you an answer and uncertainty will
tell me whether it fits
hmm that was a joke so this system is
particularly so the filtering happens on
the fly so I can filter each movement in
the side targeted not targeted or
deliberate not deliberate the classifier
is trained on you once and then you know
it you don't need to you do not need any
additional data to make it better it's
it's ready for use it's particularly
effective for within-subjects comparison
so for example if person interacts with
two different user interfaces are with
two different input devices you can you
can use it to really well compare these
two different circumstances in the same
person's life things get a teensy bit
trickier in the between-subjects
comparisons because it is possible that
you know that the thing that I'm looking
for the thing that I considered to be
ideal lab-based movement for some people
will will fit even within kind of
distracted behavior and for some people
many of them you know most deliberate
movements will not look like Luud
movements but was just a little bit of
exposure to a person were able to adapt
to it as a researcher I am searching for
particular results and i RZ don't want
to bias my results but if i had the
opportunity to filter that is throw up
data that doesn't fit when i'm looking
for uh then in that sense how do i how
do I keep this method let's say
responsible how do I fold it accountable
for the data that I've grown out because
i was searching for particular results
okay so we actually validate their inst
five different metrics to make sure kind
of the most basic kinds of measurements
that we can enter now is that we do with
motor performance data we kind of found
the solution that was good on all of
them and we assume that having validated
the method against the most typical
questions that would ask so for example
computation of fits all parameters and
throughput we what we get in the wild is
almost the same as as in the lab the
identification of statistically
different different
significant differences among people so
wherever there was a statistic signature
and difference between people in the lab
we also observed those in in our
filtered data we looked at ricoh of the
of the movements that we knew were
deliberate and targeted so we so we we
made many many we perform many different
checks they worked out so we believe
that if we so if I so if I now take this
system towards a new task it's not
optimized towards the kind of data that
I would like to see for this new task
it's kind of optimized for the typical
questions we asked him in motor
performance research in pointing
research so I think you can trust it so
so in summary we've built a you know a
tool that is using independent situation
dependent that you can apply to perform
motor performance research in the wild
one quick digression I kind of made a
big deal out of using this special
classifying in our research the the
reason why i want to point it out is
because often when people use machine
learning tools in human-computer
interaction people try to shoehorn HC a
situation situations to the most common
models used in machine learning but
often the most common models do not
quite match the semantics of what's
happening in the interactive system so
here you saw an example when we collect
the lab lab based pointing movements
they're positive examples but pointing
examples collected in situ are not
negative examples that they are in fact
unlabeled when you bookmark a web page
it's a positive example of something
that you're interested in but every
other page that you see is not a
negative example of it does these are
not pages that we are not interested in
just because you haven't booked mode
them there mix of pages that you may or
may not be interested in so you actually
do not know what they are when you go to
chi and you use the converse system and
you start some talks those that you
start you're probably interested in but
those that you haven't touched may or
may not be of interest to you so this is
just one kind of situation where well
you know the real world HCI situation
does not match the typical semantics of
a machine learning model where you have
to look for more exotic semantics in
some cases you will be lucky and
somebody else will have already built a
model that matches the real semantics of
what's happening in your system but in
some situations you will actually have
to either built your own or collaborate
with a colleague and they'll be grateful
to you because they all have a high
quality real motivation to solve yet
another new and exotic and novel machine
learning problem so now I'd like to move
on to the kind of bigger part of the
targeted the lab in the wild platform
three years ago we really wild
experiment proving whether were there
are applications of that you had in the
end we work to deploy them with with
people with motor impairments it's with
the help of medical collaborators and
those collaborations are very slow to
bear fruit so we are working on it but
it has not yet happened in collaboration
what do you want to learn river war so
I'm really interested in in really
understanding the spectrum of individual
differences among people with with motor
impairments so I was trying to cover it
with people with medical doctors who
work with people with Parkinson's
muscular dystrophy MS and all sorts of
neuro motor disorders so said I could
collect large quantities of data from
people with these very unusual motor
abilities so they could you know
understand what is the true
dimensionality of the of the
unusual motor abilities unusual
abilities yes so one of my whether my
big interest is adapting to individual
differences among people I've built
previously systems that automatically
generate using interfaces adapted to
individuals with motor impairments and
by analyzing the the designs of my
systems produced in the past it's quite
clear that the dimensionality of the
space of motor disabilities is actually
not as big as I initially felt it can
probably be described by three or four
or five dimensions I do not yet know
what they are and I will not know until
I've collected enough data to figure it
out as a comparison total aside it
wasn't until about a hundred of years
ago that people figured out a sizing
system for women's clothing initially
tailors would take over fifty
measurements in when they wanted to
produce a piece of clothing for women
and that made it very difficult to
mass-produce clothing for women so nest
actually sent out measured measurement
people into the wild for three years
collected lots and lots of samples then
had days that decisions work on paper
for another three years and they
eventually figured out that you could
describe women's clothing was just a
handful of numbers and one discrete
variable so we want to do the same for
mother motor disabilities ok let me new
world we've built a site that hosts a
large number of design relevant
behavioral experiments people come and
people participate in these experiments
because they want to those experiments
tend to be short 7 to 15 minutes and in
the past three years we've got over 3
million visitors another 1 million
completed experiments the immediate
question that everybody asks when we
tell them about flooding the wilder when
we try to publish the results as you
know can we trust your data and you know
the common assumption is that when you
bring people to the lab they behave
themselves but if you don't look after
them day they will behave in ways that
are detrimental to the quality of the
data that that you are trying to collect
so we run to validation experiments to
try to compare the data that we get at
nine with the wild with with the data
we that other people have obtained in
real laboratory settings so one of these
experiments is a famous experiment by
sternberg from a long long time ago in
which which measures some one aspect of
people's short-term memory so people
participating in this experiment are
asked to memorize a sequence of of
symbols and then they are presented with
one symbol at the time and they asked to
say was this symbol in the said that
they've just memorized I was it not they
finding the key finding in the original
experiment is that the response time
grows linearly with the number of
symbols that people had to remember in
the first place so it essentially shows
that we scan our working memory our
short-term memory sequentially rather
than accessing it associativity or in
any other way and there's a very
beautiful linear fit so the first thing
that we checked with our lab in the wild
data was do we reproduce this finding do
we get do we get a good learning effort
and we get a beautiful beautiful linear
fit another finding related to the
original experiment is that even though
the absolute speed with which people may
respond may change the slope of this fit
is insensitive to training so there are
no learning effects when it comes to the
to the slope and again we looked at both
first-timers and people who had done
this experiment multiple times in lab in
the wild and we find that there is no
substantial or significant difference in
the slope there are no prominent
learning effects another validation
another result that we looked at is at
the accuracy with which people answer
these yes or no questions in the in the
way the way you analyze the results of
this experiment is that you throw away
everyone who had accuracy lower than
ninety-five percent so we did we did it
as well but we actually looked at the
percentage of the people that that made
mistakes percentage of mistakes in each
of the difficulty levels in lab in the
wild setting and in one true laboratory
setting that showed these results and we
find that found that our participants
actually made few
wearers especially on the hardest tasks
then under graduates who have paid to
come to a laboratory and perform this
task and I'll tell you in just a couple
of minutes why we think our people work
harder than people that you bring to the
lab and pay them another experiment that
we did was the reading the mind in the
ice test in this test people have
presented with just the eyes part of a
person's face and I presented with with
four possible emotions and they asked to
pick what emotion this face is trying to
communicate and this experiment was
originally conducted in Britain because
lab in the world is accessed by people
from all over the world we're able to
pick participants demographics that
matched exactly the participant
demographics used in the in the original
study and there were no significant or
substantial differences between our
results all the results obtained in the
in the original study we're also able to
extend the original results so one one
thing that became very clear is that
this test is very cultured dependent it
works very well in Western cultures it
works very differently in cultures where
emotions are communicated different in
private and in public discourse and this
is this this is controlling fo for the
English language skill and four and for
frequency of computer use which with two
extraneous factors that would also
affect performance we also notice that
there's the not very big but significant
age-related differences that follow the
typical curves of of cognitive
development that shows that the theory
of mine skills actually do change
throughout lifetime so we are fairly
confident that the data that we collect
on lab in the wild are reliable when we
present people with these cognitively
demanding tasks they actually are
putting serious cognitive effort into
memorizing these sets and and you know
working hard and when we ask them to
perform these effortful subjective
judgments with the reading diets in the
minders they also do it honestly and
well and the question is you know why is
it happening why are participant
behaving so well one decision that we
that we made in designing lab in the
wild that that we think is responsible
for this is that we reward people
scarcity we do not rely on altruism we
do not rely on money but instead we tell
people take this test find out something
about yourself and compare compare
yourself to others and people want to
look good in their own eyes people want
to be better than them their friends and
this seems to really impact people's
performance and at the end of every
study we tell them you know how they did
and how it compares to others and often
we try to you know put the put it in
perspective and you know you know
synthesize the data in in a variety of
interesting ways and you know this bribe
works in a very you know is not always
equally successful so you know one of
our study attracted half a million
people whereas others attracted fewer
but you know even our less successful
studies easily gets ten thousand or more
participants so you know this is
substantially larger than n equals 15
another thing that I think we do right
is that now we didn't do it initially we
make all of the potentially tedious
things optional so we tell people you
know please fill out this demographic
question at please please please and you
know if you if you are lazy just do this
first for but we do not require it we
found that when we require that people
would you know some of the people were
sudden you were born in Antarctica right
or Afghanistan or anything else starting
in a so we thought that it was better to
get a few smaller quantity of data but
more trustworthy data than to insist on
everybody providing us with data
depending on the on the on the system on
the on the test you know maybe up to one
third of the people choose to skip some
of the questions that that's fine
because those who do provide answers all
of our checks showed that the dancers
are truthful and then also we help we
will provide a number of mechanisms
through which participants can tell us
whether the data have been in any way
compromised so for example we always ask
participants whether they've taken a
particular test before
we give them plenty of opportunities to
give us comments and in particular we
ask them whether they you know they
experienced in the difficulties and
whether they've cheated and they tell us
they tell us very interesting things Sam
you would you know expect some you
wouldn't we seem to have a very
interesting relationship with substances
and that goes both ways and we also have
very interesting relationships with
educational institutions all right so
with this in place I would like to show
you two studies two novel studies that
we conducted that actually allow it
allowed us to do novel science you know
with the help of lab in the world so the
first piece of work that we did was on
understanding people's perception of
aesthetic appeal and now wake up because
there's going to be a test are you
paying attention to the screen okay so
watch carefully how many of you would
consider making a purchase from a
website that that was designed with this
kind of visual aesthetics okay very
ancient age how many of you would
consider making a purchase from a
website that look like this one okay
good job can I have your credit card
number they interesting here interesting
thing here is not that you know the
specific answers that you gave but the
fact that you quite confidently gave
answers in both both of these cases and
that they were actually different and
this effect has been well documented the
your first impression of aesthetic
appeal mediates your your perception of
the trustworthiness of a digital
resource it mediates your willingness to
engage with the resource and even more
importantly
mediates your actual success using that
resource so if something is ugly and you
encounter a problem because your
experience negative affect you will be
trying the same thing over and over
again you're sending speedy you
experience positive effect you will try
something different so they're actually
measurable usability effects of of
aesthetics two aspects of a visual
design that impact perception of
aesthetic appeal the most colorful ness
and visual complexity so the first thing
that we did in this study was to build a
computational model based in computer
vision that given the design analyzes
both the the special structure and the
colorfulness of the design and is able
to produce a predictions of of the
colorfulness and visual complexity that
matches very well with people's actually
subjective ideas of California scent and
visual complexity so building on on this
tool on the stool that is that allows us
to you know put in a visual design of a
website and get two numbers that
describe the properties of this visual
design we tried to build a model that
would predict how much people would like
different designs given the California's
visual complexity and their demographics
so we conducted the study on live in the
wild with 40,000 people and a large
number of designs and we're able to
characterize what's happening so for
example for the visual complexity there
is definite peak the designs that are
too simple or too complex and not liked
as much as those that are just in the
right place and these are examples of
the designs that kind of seem to fit in
the sweet spot for for the general
population for when we aggregate over
everyone we get kind of the same you
know phenomenon for for colorfulness and
obviously when we start looking at
individual demographics we start seeing
differences and some of them you know
enforce the stereotypes if you add color
to to a design Germans get upset
charians cannot get enough when you look
at education the more time we spent in
school the more boring websites we like
so
our appreciation for calendars decreases
so we were able to create a model that
explains you know almost half of the
variance in in in the ratings of people
people's first impressions of aesthetic
appeal so so fairly good predictor I
mean obviously not ideal but for
computational predictor is pretty good
and it takes into account both the kind
of objective properties of the website
and to your demographics and puts it all
together and makes a prediction on the
side I told you that I was quite
concerned with the one-size-fits-all
design and its potential discriminative
discriminatory effects so here are some
you know observations qualitative
observations that we've made we've
realized that for example the design of
many of the MOOC websites kind of hyper
optimized for educated Westerners and
discriminate discriminate against people
from other parts of the world with less
access to formal education these are
examples of websites that appeal to
women much more than men and these are
examples of sites that appealed to men
much more than women notice that the
latter two both websites a teacher
technical skills or give you access to
technical resources we want more women
in computer science but the resources
that we build you know I appeal to men
way more to women so even before they
try we kind of already make them less
likely to trust us less likely to engage
and less likely to succeed just small
things but they adapt so to synthesize
this study prior research has told us
that first impression of aesthetic
appeal mediates perception of trust
perception of willingness to engagements
usability it also told us that
complexity and California's the key
factors that predict first impression of
aesthetic appeal and T now a study we've
built a model that is able to predict
the aesthetic appeal of a visual design
of a website we've presented evidence of
you know fairly large individual
differences among in first impressions
of visual appeal across populations and
that they correlate it with demographics
and we also you know
study was only possible because we had
access to very heterogeneous pull of
participants from all over the world yes
sir sure still change for less than a
second I guess so do Bieber from their
first impressions that quickly yeah in
fact 30 more seconds is enough and they
showed them to you followed by animals
against so that their prior studies that
compared your impressions after you know
50 milliseconds and after an extended
exposure and they show that there is a
very high correlation so we form
immediate and lasting impressions in
incredibly cooking how does the styling
run was at alternative forced choice and
you know how many how many of these did
a single person have to do and so
efficient so fewer than 20 and they saw
them twice today so 20 in a random order
then there was a break and then they saw
these things again in a different order
they were told that they will they
weren't told that there would be I'll be
that they would all be the same but they
were warned that there would be some
repeats and we we looked at the
correlation between the responses in the
first phase in the second phase to
figure out whether they were really
making an effort full effort what was
the response of the response was a 99
point I could scale asking you know how
visually appealing is this website at
each other so you're shown selling for
500 milliseconds question 500
milliseconds question and we were very
little who was paying attention and who
wasn't by showing the same designs twice
another change
what features are you training of the
complexity oh my goodness this is just
like every feature you can find or you
know are coded the there were 40 just so
so there were several previous studies
that either quality qualitatively a
computation he analyzed visual
complexity and California's we built on
all of them we collaborated with Tommy
year at Boulder university of
colorado-boulder we implemented all of
them and a subset of them turned out to
be very strong predictors of people's
actual perceptions of so I can't
remember the names of the authors from
whom we borrowed the teachers pellets
our our relations between predators
complexity and California's and the
actual complexity in California's were
like point seven so they do it very very
high I don't think you can get much
higher given that people are noisy there
isn't going I mean people say okay so we
chose to use people's ratings as a
ground truth I've got formula since very
exciting results are noticeable later so
we run a cross-sectional study of
age-related differences in motor
performance we give people this task in
which we we told them to click on on the
dots and we told them that they dint
would try to guess the age and indeed we
did not very accurately but we also has
them way you know how far off where we
tell us your real age so we had lots and
lots of data half a million participants
did it so we had moto traces from half a
million people and their actual ages we
extracted lots and lots and lots of
features from it here is a subset of
them we ran a factor analysis on them
and this actually turned out quite
interesting so as you would expect some
features predict people's speed and
strength sampath something's classic
clearly around fine motor control others
are
review a cognitive processing speed but
there's a separate set of features that
I've just related to the path quality
that not correlate with anything else
and I'll explain to you why I think that
they are actually really distinct and
then errors add their own factor so we
perform this factor analysis in a
variety of different ways with different
assumptions and it always came out the
same so we actually fairly confident
that they're actually five underlying
aspects of our motor performance system
so strength so given that we had a very
large number of data we're able to
actually estimate you know each each of
these features for each year in a
person's life from 5 to 75 to 85 and we
see very interesting patterns that you
know coralie it was quite well with what
psychologists had predicted
qualitatively so strength peaks in like
20 cents and that's to be expected there
is a dip in college we don't know why
fine motor control improves dramatically
till till late teens and then we get
worse and worse and worse lower is
better here cognitive processing speed
the two measures that we use for it at
the initiation time so quickly how
quickly you begin a movement after the
stimulus onset and how much time do you
spend between when you stop on the
target and when you click so the time
that you spend ascertaining that you
really are on target and these things
just like fine motor control peak in the
late teens again exactly what
psychologists would predict
interestingly however errors decrease
throughout life so you know the highest
in in early teens and then as we age we
will become more and more and more
accurate the a couple of prior studies
that show that all the adults make
different speed accuracy trade-offs then
than younger adults it's a it's a higher
cognitive choice it's not related to
actual low level abilities and then you
get the most interesting results which
is the past quality which has a very
strange shape it seems like from early
teens till about the age of 20 what's
responsible for the improvement
in the in the path quality is as the
improvement of your in your actual fine
motor control abilities but afterwards
even though your abilities decline after
after late teens your movement error and
your movement variability still get
better and better and better and we
think that this is where they kind of
the high level cognitive trade-off of
the disputed speed and accuracy
trade-off is responsible for the results
you know your errors keep decreasing you
you are paying more attention to being
accurate even though your abilities
decline and this is probably what's
responsible for this effect so we
conducted a large study we were able to
characterize how these abilities change
throughout our lifetimes when they peek
very interestingly children become
better at seven times the rate at which
adults become worse so when you design
for children they within a single
classroom when you design for
schoolchildren you will have dramatic
differences in motor abilities so when
you design testing situations or any
other educational interventions that
rely on on soon level of motor
performance allow for the fact that you
will have fairly vast differences so
make sure that people's success does not
depend on the lower level motor
performance abilities and the one
interesting novel finding is that
there's this aspect of motor performance
the path quality that seems to depend on
two separate factors in interesting ways
so this is the end we've done a number
of projects trying to expand our
empirical target I should two of them
with you I've showed you two studies
that were able to to run only because we
we've expanded our toolkit and that's it
so sorry in this technically married
with a shorter performance wouldn't
there be a significant difference
between users on a laptop with that you
know touchpad or whatever and users
using a mouse yes so so these results
control for that so we we had touchpad
users we've got Mouse users and other
input devices users very interestingly
we also saw operating systems related
differences that so the operating system
correlates with with the kind of age of
the hardware so typically more recent
operating systems I also running on more
recent hardware we saw a very
interesting trend were on Windows
people's performance was getting worse
and worse with the latent later releases
of the operating system whereas on the
market was getting better and better
trackpad tends to perform typically
worse than the mouse but Apple was able
to bring the performance of the 22 part
they were actually as good worse on on
Windows the trackpad performance was was
diverging from from the mouse
performance so yeah they're very
interesting differences related to the
to both the hardware and software and
and we sediment we controlled for them
in these results see so we will yeah so
so whether they were using a mouse or
touchpad was self-reported and they're
very clear differences like when you
look at the data you can clearly see
what's Mouse what's trackpad and as far
as we can tell people set reports were
accurate so it seems like such a power
tool when you really gravitate these
studies cross-culturally answer like
patiences but we also know and you
mentioned that your incentives really
affect your accuracy I was curious if
you knew of any work in differences in
the effectiveness of incentives across
cultures and whether
role in the differences in accuracy we
see across cultures talk to the guy
behind me okay so I believe they exist
yeah and and and and we can actually we
in our motor performance data we
actually see substantial cultural
differences that indicate that in some
cultures people prefer the accuracy of a
speed and in others they preferred speed
of accuracy so so that that actually you
know directly shows that what people are
instant device to do and how they
incentivize does differ but I cannot
characterize these differences man okay
oh so um you showed us some experiments
that you love in the wild ah very nice
and interesting results and then you
also spent a little bit of time talking
about some of the findings you had about
how to run experiments in a while um do
you uh you know have you tested those
things what's what's the again what's
the goal for lab in a while and you know
where do you want to take this case is
not efficient so how do I know the
reason is they build your intro some of
it we know by analyzing the social media
posts about lab in the wild and the
things that people chose to say some of
it we know from people come from the
analysis of the comments some of it is
kind of our own speculation about the
causal mechanisms then without the
survey or we can without the Sith the
reports about your personal scores yeah
we found that there were big effects
that we won't commit at first but right
now we're we're we're building self and
elevate and baby testing infrastructure
so that we can precise the answer these
questions both in how we frame the
incentives and how we are the things at
at which places people drop out you know
how this is the wording and the choices
that we make
affect people's self-reported and three
other performance yes we're doing all of
these things I mean this is just such a
fertile ground we can do so many
different things so we are also actually
interested so we've kind of replicated
the number of I traditional
experiments but we're also trying to
push the boundary of what can we of what
we can do in this space so Power had
attempted to run a creativity study in
which people both work create events
provide a judgment on other people's
creative outcome that's something that
hasn't been run in this kind of setting
we are looking at bilingual studies we
are looking at a number of other things
that have not yet been run in
large-scale settings so um yeah very
much kidney candy store kind of question
here staring your subtitle tools for
large-scale experiment asian HDI in many
ways I feel like there's a huge
opportunity cuz you know I think you've
done some of this work but I feel like
what you described as large the tools
for large-scale correlation in HCI and
like the opportunity to run randomized
controlled experiments that are
manipulating there's a million to the
gold standard because you're owning was
Puckle happy song so I wanted to probe
some of your some of your motivations in
the particular studies you ran and in
what in which cases you were looking for
you know what guided you toward those
verses things that that were potentially
more our CT style style experiments so
the new experiments are you know within
subjects multi condition experiments so
I obviously have an adaptive user
interfaces experiment that is presented
as a as a multitasking experiment
because it combines you know very cell
varying levels of cognitive load with
different kinds of adaptation so we we
are rolling out the the true experiments
you see you what have we miss because we
couldn't do that then you feel like you
can get that now obviously there's just
a huge range of stuff but like what what
do you think is the so you're the kid in
candy store because you because you got
you in
have this platform you know what are the
most attractive questions in HCI that
you think we have been able to get at
that if you had a small army of
interesting graduate students you go out
okay so first thing is as we're working
on opening I'm lab in the wild and we to
to other researchers and we we are
currently recruiting people who are
willing to work with us on beta basis to
figure out you know how we should
structure this relationship so we are we
do have several external rage
researchers working with us so we are
opening up the candy store Katarina is
incredibly excited about cross cultural
research without having to go to wonder
every time she has a new question and
she has been able to conduct
cross-cultural research but which is you
know quite interesting because in
different country you sample a different
skewed subpopulation and you have to
correct for that I am very excited about
understanding the breadth of individual
differences that that I present among
people understanding how they impact
people's engagement and success with
interactive systems and you know I'm
interested in finding opportunities for
making access to digital resources
fairer and more more equitable and in
both of these cases we are relying on
the fact that we are accessing a much
more diverse and much more
representative population than we would
have if we only brought undergrads into
a lab so so it's not just the scale it's
the diversity of the population that
that has been perfectly important to us
and you know the very important aspect
of all large scale experimentation
platforms is not just that your n is
larger but the fact that the theater to
experiment cycle is shortened so as you
as you see changes that you need to make
in your experiment as you see other
conditions as you see are the sub
questions you can turn these around
incredibly quickly and you know you can
produce your science so much faster and
you can go after risky questions because
the cost is lava I believe I'm allowed
one more question and
that was I was wondering if you saw a
lot more variability in both extremes of
age and I was wondering if any of that
is due to the fact that you probably
have smaller numbers in the sample at
the ends yes they're assessing that so
there isn't the standard deviation
wasn't much larger in those areas was a
little bit larger but the sample sizes
were much smaller okay job last year
question just to follow up on Michaels
point do you think the way we run
experiments with interactive systems for
instance if I were to write a kite paper
and you know recruit 12 people around
campus to do some task that idea in
using my system versus having
potentially 10,000 people on live in the
wild using my system so I'm curious
about where you think the right balance
or the right direction as a community
that wants to produce referenceable
results of science so every tool has
different produce so I think this was
pretty clear very well if if you want
external validity if you believe that
your results really handle getting more
representative sample then the
undergraduate students I think it's very
important very useful if you go up to
small effect sizes right because you
need much larger samples to detect small
effect sizes it's very helpful if you
want to compare a large number of
conditions right because with a with a
large pool you can write run mixed with
in between subjects experiments and you
know Annalise sixteen twenty a hundred
different conditions and kind of do that
kind of exploratory study so I don't
think you should do every experiment on
live in the wild but I want you to have
to like that in your toolkit so it when
you when you have an empirical question
you can make an informed decision and
pick the tool that is right for the
problem and not pick the only tool that
you have
thank you all right
you